Once you've got the order on y and x right, the rest should be pretty straightforward.
We're going one step left, we're going one step right, we're going one step down,
we're going one step up, and subject four times the original value.
And the result is that our initial square has turned into a soft blob.
In case you're wondering, we're using 50 steps from the left to the right
and from the bottom to the top.
How could we get such a smooth picture with just 50  50 values. The trick is interpolation.
So let's switch off interpolation to see how our raw data really look like.
Now, you can see those 50 steps in x direction and y direction.
Interpolation turns this pixelated image into one that looks really smooth.